So how do you handle
setbacks at the company now?
>> One of the best pieces of
management advice that I've ever read,
actually my cofounder Dan spoke
with Dick Coslow at Twitter.
And Dick said something that has
stuck with me ever since, and
it's that the hardest thing about
management is making everyone else
understand what you understand.
And when you think about this from
a problem solving context, first of all,
there are always problems.
There's always something blowing up or
something going wrong, and
it's really hard as a growing manager,
I'd never had any experience doing this.
My cofounder hadn't either.
It's a really, really difficult
thing to train yourself to,
when something goes really wrong, don't
try and solve the problem yourself.
Instead think of your job as getting
everybody else to understand as much as
they can about the problem.
And so, you might think that your job as
a leader is to sort of present a happy
face and make it seem like everything's
rosy all the time to motivate people.
But it's actually not the job,
the job is to make everybody as aware
of the problems as possible and
to help get them rallied
around solving them instead.
And so that means confronting things
openly, being aware of reality and
trying to communicate as much as
you can with the team about it